we're right okay
good afternoon everyone today welcome
everybody to this
uh licensing subcommittee for friday
the 9th of october um via zoom
the first item is attendances so what i
think we'll do is some
introductions i'm councillor david
german i'm
chairing the committee so we can ask the
other two committee members to
introduce themselves first i'm
councillor barry brotherton
and i'm councillor dylan butt on the
member of this committee thank you
can i ask the league or the legal
officer licensing officer in the class
to introduce themselves
please
yeah my name is john boyle i'm the
licensing team leader
i'm sadie lenahan solicitor from
trafford council
that's leo and democratic services
officer
okay and um we have people attending for
well the only item really that we're
considering today
which is the application for the grant
of a premises license
um a common ground uh 20 shaw's role
culturing them now do we have a
miss tullock for the applicant yes
afternoon chair good afternoon and do
you have a
mr b hey good afternoon
oh good afternoon and uh nazarene ali
from our
environmental health yes good afternoon
chair
and everybody else hello nasri
um right so
just to just to uh run through the
the order of procedure what i'll do is
ask the licensing officer to outline the
application
then i'll ask the applicant or the
applicant's representative
to up to outline the application from
from their
point of view and then after that
they'll be questioned by
the panel officers on under uh and the
representative
um after that the representator uh
the environmental health officer will
put her case
and then after that she can be
questioned by the applicant
uh the sorry the committee the officers
and the applicant in that order
um so then i would ask all parties to
summarize um
starting with the representative and
then the applicant
and then there will be a briefing by the
legal officer
before we will go into a private session
to
uh to determine the outcome so is that
everybody
clear about that are there any questions
okay can i i ask uh joanne
go on board please to outline the
application thank you chair members of
the subcommittee
um the licensing act 2003 provides that
a premises license is required in
respect
of any premises where it is intended to
conduct
one or more of the four licensable
activities these being the sale of
alcohol
supply of alcohol in respect to the
members club regulated entertainment
and or the provision of late night
refreshment
an application for a premises license
has been submitted to the authority
by kite solicitors on behalf of the
applicant common ground coffee limited
in respect to premises at 20 shaw's road
in altering him
the premises are currently not licensed
and and are described as a coffee shop
and bar trading on the ground first and
second floors
the licensable activity applied for are
films
live music and recorded music indoors
supply of alcohol both on and off the
premises
and late night refreshment indoors the
days and hours applied for are detailed
in the report
in terms of the application process the
licensing section is satisfied that the
application has been made properly
and all the procedures followed
including the advertising and
notification of the application a copy
of the application and location plans
are attached to the report at
appendix a and a photograph the blue
notice
and a copy of the newspaper advert are
attached at appendix b
the applicant has completed an operating
schedule as part of the application
which outlines what measures will be in
place
to promote the full licensing objectives
and which would become conditions on the
license if granted
the those measures are listed in the
report at section three
during the consultation the authority
received one representation
the representation is from nazarene ali
from the council's pollution team who
has objected to the application
in respect of the use of the first and
second floors of the premises
on the grounds of public nuisance
missoli does not object to the
application in respect of the ground
floor
provided the measures um proposed in the
operating schedule
are applied together with the additional
conditions which she has suggested
in her representation a copy of miss
ali's
full representation is attached to the
committee report at appendix c
finally the subcommittee should know
that the premises are situated
in ultragum town center which is an area
identified in the council's special
saturation policy
as a cumulative impact zone cumulative
impact means that there is a potential
impact on the promotion of the licensing
objectives of having a significant
number
of licensed premises concentrated in one
area
the effects of adopting a special
saturation policy
is to create a rebuttal presumption the
applications for new premises licenses
license licenses in the areas identified
be refused if that is relevant
representations to the effect
i received and unless it can be
demonstrated that this
operation of the premises will not add
to the cumulative impact
already being experienced applicants
should therefore address the special
policy issues in their operating
schedules in order to rebut
such a presumption the fact that the
authority has a special saturation
policy doesn't mean however that
applications are automatically refused
policy does allow for each application
to be considered on its own merits and
the applications that are
unlikely to add to the cumulative impact
can be granted
the project the representation from the
pollution team doesn't refer to the
saturation policy however
the premises does lie within that zone
and the subcommittee should consider if
the operation of these
particular premises would add to the
cumulative impact
in the area in order to determine that
the subcommittee should consider
such factors as the occupancy of the
premises
the proximity of the premises to other
similar premises in the area
how the premises will be managed by
reference to the operating schedule
the hours of operation and the transport
provision
um and if there's any dispersal policy
proposed by the applicant
in closing i'd invite the subcommittee
to consider the report the written
and verbal submissions of the applicant
and miss ali and having regard to
national guidance and the council's own
licensing policy
take such steps as it considers
necessary for the promotion of the
licensing objectives
and that's all i propose to say at this
time chair unless the members have any
questions for me anybody have any
questions
for the licensing officer
um not a question sorry my voice uh not
a question
as such chair but the the premises on
the ground floor does already benefit
from a premises license
um i think well you mentioned that it
wasn't currently licensed
it is it's been licensed for a number of
years colleges
um but obviously the application is for
a new license because
um we're increasing those hours and
going into the upper level so
a new license was felt preferable rather
than a variation to the existing one
thank you
will you be representing the applicant
then would you like to
carry on with your submission
yes thank you very much chair um i don't
propose to talk much more about the
terms of the application
um because joanne has set out exactly
what it is that
has been applied for um damien has owned
the premises for a couple of years
but it has been licensed for longer than
that
the application seeks to
go into the first and second floors
part of the building which damien
already owns um
to enable him to provide licensable
activities up there
as well we believe that if you were to
grant the license
the licensing objectives would not be
undermined for a number of reasons
firstly as joanne mentioned we submitted
a an operating schedule with the
application
which in our view was robust and
thorough
and goes beyond those conditions which
are currently attached to
the existing license
and if i can draw your attention in a
particular to two conditions which we've
offered which i think go to the heart of
the concerns which nazarene has and that
is the escape of
noise from the first and second floors
and the potential that the use of those
floors might have
to disturb those who might live nearby
and those are found
in your papers at 3.16 and 3.17
of the operating schedule 3.16 says that
noise from amplified music or voices
shall not be such as to cause a nuisance
to occupants of nearby
premises and 3.17 says no noise shall
emanate from the premises
nor vibration be transmitted through the
structure of the premises
which gives rise to a nuisance and
nazarene and her representation
um asked us to consider accepting
a number of other conditions which
mike damien is more than happy to do so
and that has already been communicated
to nazarene
and within those conditions i would want
to draw your attention in particular to
ppn3
which reads noise from music and
associated sources
must not be audible to such an extent
that it constitutes a nuisance
any noise sensitive premises and it
would be our
submission that those conditions
combined with
the others uh both offered by us and
agreed
um following nazarene's objection
from a robust set which guarantees that
a nuisance won't be caused to anyone
living
in the vicinity uh you'll have seen in
the papers that there have there has
been
discussions regarding the occupancy of
um a flat uh nearby to the premises
um there is a flat above sugo
italian restaurant at first floor level
which is adjacent to the first
floor of common ground
the resident there is amy williams and
you should have before you an email from
her
that was submitted earlier this week in
which she explains that she's happy
with the terms of the application she
has no objections to
it and wishes for it to be granted
and not refused on her account
and i think there was some confusion
about whether there were any other
residents
near um to amy uh she is a department
three but there has been reference to
apartments one and two
during the course of discussions but i
think it's been confirmed
by an email submitted by nazarene this
week
from the landlord that there are in fact
no other occupants
above sugo there appears to be plans to
develop them but at the moment there's
only one occupied by amy
and she's happy with the application
and i think i would say that we can't
speculate at this time as to
whether future residents of flat flats
which have yet to be developed may or
may
not be um disturbed or may or may not
object
um to an applicant an application or a
license such as this
i think what we would say is that the uh
the conditions that have been offered
will ensure that regardless of whatever
license activities take place
on those floors noise will not escape
and disturbance will not arise
as a result since the consultation
period ended um
damian and i uh have been in uh contact
with nazarene to discuss her concerns
um we've spoken we've emailed
we've suggested a and offered a meeting
on site to try and resolve matters
but unfortunately we've not been able to
do so
but we have narrowed the issues somewhat
as i've said we've agreed to the various
conditions
that she requested more than
happy to do so we've also
offered to reduce the hours that we have
applied for
you'll see in the papers before you that
the
the hours sought were until midnight uh
during the week
and one o'clock at we ken's um
communicated at the end of september to
nazarene that
we would no longer be seeking one
o'clock terminal hour at the weekends
and so if you reminded to grant the
application today we would ask that it
was granted until midnight
daily for licensable activities with an
additional 30 minutes thereafter
to allow for dispersal
and that in our view would give um or
would result in a relatively standard
license for the area um the common
ground is opposite the market
right in the center of altringham next
to suga which has a license until 11
the seller with a license until midnight
during the week and 2 a.m at weekends
and a couple of doors down from pi which
has a license until 2 a.m daily
and a license was granted earlier this
year from an application which
i submitted on behalf of another
operator um until midnight
daily um opposite on the former nobles
amusement
arcade site uh reference has obviously
been made to the existence of the
cumulative impact
policy that is in force for altering um
consciousness yet um but as ms boyle
pointed out
um it's not been referenced in
nazarene's objection she's not asking
for the application to be refused
as you've heard she has no issues with
the operation of the premises
on the ground floor it's the issue of
the
the use of the first and second there
have been
as you'll be aware no objections from
the police none from any other licensing
uh sorry license license licensing
authorities any other responsible
authorities
um and none from any residents at all
um we've had regard to it when
formulating the application and it was
done so
um in light of it um
but i think i would say that licenses
have been granted regularly
um whilst the policy has been in force
um and successfully indeed the common
ground license
um the original first common ground
license was granted
uh notwithstanding the existence of that
policy so whilst of course you must have
regard to it
um i would ask that you you grant the
license
in spite of its existence
this application is made against a
rather unusual backdrop
the hospitality sector over the last six
months or so
has faced um huge
hurdles and difficulties a long period
of lockdown
followed by a brief respite but now what
appears to be
an imminent further closure for a period
of time
certainly in the north from perhaps as
early as next week
altering them though has thrived um
during that period of reopening perhaps
more so than
areas um such as city centres
um people more people are working from
home
going out more locally and rather than
journeying into
city centres more are staying local and
i think
we would we would ask you and urge you
to grant the license to enable
the town centre to continue to thrive it
is now
after years of um under use
uh a very successful and award-winning
town centre
i moved here a couple of years ago
because of what it offers
and the the role that um
cafes restaurants bars play in the
regeneration of the
area i don't think can be underestimated
um and so i'd ask um as i've said
um i think in summary i would say the
only person who could be reasonably
expected to be impacted
by the application is amy williams the
nearest neighbor
but she doesn't want you to refuse it
she wants you to grant it and there are
the safeguards as i've said
in place that if you were to do so
there's no risk the licensing objectives
or to her immunity um if the license
were to be
uh in place so unless you have any um
questions of myself
or damien um then that's the application
in summary thank you
thank you mr um can i just ask you we've
had sight of an email
um by another dream ali from the
landlord of the property next door
because he he's obviously looking to
market those
apartments shortly and he doesn't know
who's going to
get there obviously he wants to attract
the widest uh
scope possible of a customer
um now they might not be so caves mr
woodlands obviously
to to live next door to something where
the noise and vibration are coming
through the walls
so i just wondered how oh you could
guarantee that that
that wouldn't actually happen yes
the three conditions uh the two which we
offered
and the third which we've agreed at
nazarene's request
will create legally binding requirement
on damien
not to cause any issues whether that's
by noise breakout
vibration um or or any associated
issues and enforcement action can be
taken um
against any breach of those conditions
um the the landlord is um
amy williams is landlord um
and at the moment there the other flats
aren't there they've not yet been
developed
um and whilst we may speculate on what
might happen in the future at the moment
the only resident next door is miss
williams
okay can i just ask does the premises at
this stage have planning permission for
the
first and second floor operating as a
happy bar yeah
damien's nodding i'm not a planning
expert but
um damien has i don't know if you can
confirm to the committee
yeah it's within the lease that's
granted for it that it's allowed to do
it
as a coffee bar right there's a licensed
coffee bar
right okay thank you can i just um
can i just add to that i um spoke to
colleagues in the
planning enforcement team um with regard
to the planning status of
um off the premises and and they
basically said that um
the premises was previously split into
two with the ground floor occupied by a
cafe
and the first floor is a barber's shop
i think the barb is closed in 2017
and basically the cafe expanded to
include the upstairs
so both uses now fall within use class e
therefore a change of use between the
uses um it does not require planning
permission so
um the actual premises are permitted
for that use at first and second floor
can i just add um although we're talking
about planning i just want to make it
clear
that planning isn't a relevant
consideration for this committee
um it's a separate legal um
process which you would planning would
need to consider separately
i'm not just obviously a matter of
interest um
yeah okay can i just ask the other
members of the committee if you have
a question they'd like to ask the
applicant
uh thank you chad i'll take it if it's
uh okay
one i just wanted to ask was what type
of music do you intend to be playing
there
at this venue
um damien may be able to give you a
little bit more detail um
in a minute um the application is for
live and recorded music
um we've applied for it in its amended
terms until midnight
um i think it might be worth mentioning
at this stage obviously that the live
music act provisions
would apply um in any event if the
license were granted
um in that live recording music could be
played up there until 11 pm anyway
so we're simply seeking an additional
hour um
above and beyond that that the damien
will be able to explain
more about the size of the the first and
second floors
they're modest in size um
and the music um would um
give them the flexibility the provision
for music
will give them flexibility to allow for
um a dj or a small band or an acoustic
musician um to to play up there but
david if you want to elaborate
yeah thank you i think i think you've
covered it so you know it's for a
combination of either just background
music
as we currently have the ability to do
with a coffee shop during the day time
was felicity said to have uh acoustic
music or
live poetry or small bands or a dj so
it's a combination of any of those
um to provide you know background
entertainment to people who would be
coming to eat and drink
yeah i know that i mean being the sort
gum sorry i'm saying it's being the sort
of adheres and the kind of people that
probably be
sort of uh there for entertainment
wouldn't be
looking at heavy metal or rock or any
kind of
loud yeah it would be
um you know the sort of thing we're
talking about is probably like you know
acoustic guitar
you know that sort of thing that the
clientele that we currently attract and
would
be aiming to attract in the evenings
would be the sort of people that would
be wanting to talk and have some
background music you know it
only seats approximately 30 people on
the first floor
obviously with covert spacing that's
reduced and on the second floor
pre-covered it only seats eight people
which is now down to four
so you're not talking about a ginormous
space with a massive dance floor
it's got existing tables and chairs for
people to sit down and eat and drink out
yeah okay thanks
sorry just to clarify that so the live
music would take
place on the ground floor and there
would be
a pa system on the first and second
floor is that correct
no it'd be more likely to be based on
the first floor on the first floor
right will you have a pa system on each
floor
um we currently have sonus that goes
through the building um it's not our
intention at this point to be piping the
music on both
you know all the way through it isn't a
ginormous building and it is quite open
planned so if there was a singer on the
first floor
you would hear them on the ground floor
anyway but the ground floor is where the
main bar and entrance is so
it wouldn't make any sense to have
live music on the ground floor because
of you know people
ordering obviously at the moment covered
you can't go to the bar in order anyway
but um yeah no we'll be on the first
floor
first of all right okay so what happens
on the second floor
is there any music up there well again
it's the background music you would you
would hear the music it's not a big
place so if there was a band
or a singer on the on the on the first
floor you would hear them in the second
floor it's literally
open plan up um or equally it would be a
quiet space for people who didn't want
to
listen to the singer to sit and have a
choir to drink
more like a snug all right thank you
um uh can i ask councillor brotherton if
he has any questions
yeah can i just ask about the the flats
next door
i understand one's occupied by this lady
i'll the other flats
there but unoccupied or are they in a
state of disrepair
do we know what what you know what what
are the other flats are they
imaginably or are they actually
physically just just have nothing
amy is advised from speaking to her and
obviously i know nazarene will comment
in a second
that there is no front door up there
apart from her own so to
our current understanding is that they
aren't yet developed and that they will
be developed whether they are
existing with no door or in a state of
disrepair we don't
personally know but amy is advised that
since she's been a resident
nobody else has entered the building and
the post that comes to those flats is
uncollected apart from the landlord
comes so there is only one access point
which is currently into her flat
just like to add to that um so um
what in making my sort of assessment of
this application
um i've had to review the planning
history relating to the site so
planning permission has been granted for
some time for
residential um apartments at
22 to 26 a um shores road so
um amy actually lives at number 26 so
she lives above zugo but not the sugo
that's adjacent to
common ground uh she lives so there's
it is sugo kitchen there's um a
barbershop in the middle
and then there's another sugar
restaurants i think um
and then there's um common ground amy
actually lives
the furthest away from um from common
ground
um and the two other apartments in
between so at number 22
and 24 my understanding is that
access arrangements and so on have been
um
put in place and the the premises are in
the process of being refurbished so um
when i've reviewed the the application
it's based upon what's permitted there
so
um yeah so that there is actually um
permission for the apartments although
somebody's not living there and maybe
they're being refurbished but
um the the um the owner of the property
is clearly indicated that um
you know they're going to have some
tenants in it and once
the um necessary arrangements are in
place
just to add on that nazarene when i
spoke to thornley groves who left the
flat that amy lives in
yeah um and who acted for the landlord
they had that you see there are multiple
letting agents they have no knowledge of
the other flats being
coming to the market at any time in the
future right okay
i mean i mean i can't comment in that
but there's clearly
residential property on the other side
of um
you know the application premises and
it's important to note that amy actually
lives
two doors away from your premises as
opposed to
directly adjacent to to um
to your property and even if she did
live adjacent to your property my
concerns are still
still still in existence really but um
just to confirm to councillor brotherton
um the two premises um
the two other apartments are definitely
going to be residential as indicated by
the
applicants um earlier on this year the
applicant actually did submit
a planning application for some
modifications to
uh the layout of the apartment so um
my understanding is that they were
refused on
conservation grounds but they they're
actually in the process of
going back to the planning section um
to update their plans and address the
concerns so
it's not just like a dormant um
premises that's there with no intention
of any developments and
the fact that the applicant submitted
planning applications a few months ago
clearly indicates that um you know he's
he's serious about the prospect of
having residents in there so you've got
residents very close to
um to the application premises and if
you look at the actual plans the
permitted plans
as it stands now you have two bedrooms
and a lounge
on the on the other side of the party
wall of the application premises
[Music]
and that's really where my concerns
stand you've potentially got
live music recorded music and
performance of
films etc up until
one twelve o'clock um in the morning
um every night of the every every night
so you could have a young
professional sort of living there i
understand the concept of
sort of people in amy's representation
she's talked about
um um in her email she's talked about
the fact that she lives in the town
centre
and you know appreciate i appreciate
that that's
that's her choice to live there but um
residents
who live adjacent to this particular
premises will be disturbed by noise
from the activities um so
they won't have a choice um to sort of
like walk away from that they'll be
sitting here
it's sat in their bedrooms or living
rooms etc um
being negatively affected by by noise
from the activities
live music recorded music etc um
okay can i can i just ask about the
occupancy rate i asked the applicant
about the occupancy rates in in normal
circumstances
by non-covered circumstances what would
be the occupancy rates of the three
floors
so pre-covered the top floor can seat
eight people the middle floor seats 32
people
and the ground floor seats approximately
22 people
and then you've got the outside space at
the front and the rear
okay and what about standing what what's
the maximum you can take in
in the whole parenthesis maximum
the maximum on the ground floor is 70
and then the first floor is 50.
okay thank you very much not that you
were just
finishing that you would never have that
because
you it would not be a pleasant
environment you know it isn't a
nightclub environment
it's a you know a market coffee shop
an evening place so that that wouldn't
actually ever
be something that would be realistic and
especially in covert times it's not
going to happen
anytime in the foreseeable future no
it's not happening
too has anybody got any more questions
of the applicant
in which case can i move on to
the representation nazarene if you want
to
say your piece about the the objection
you've raised
yeah that's fine thank you thank you
chair um so
basically um i received the variation
application
and reviewed the proposals
um the the application wanted to
um um the applicant wanted to uh have
live music recorded music
late night refreshment etc up until one
o'clock
um thursday to saturday and midnight
um sunday to wednesday although i
understand this has been
changed now um when reviewing the
application i looked at the
plans for the ground floor um first
floor
second floor um maximum of i think
32 covers on the first and ten on the
the second floor um i didn't have any
objections to the the proposal
um on the ground floor because it's
really in line with
other licensed premises in the area
shores road
greenwood street etc but i did object to
the
um the application for regulated
entertainment on the
first and second floors on the grounds
of public
nuisance um and and the reasons really
for the representation were the fact
that um
you've got noise sensitive um premises
adjacent to the application
premises on the upper floors so as i
said earlier you've got two bedrooms
and a lounge on the other side of the
party wall
and so noise from live music recorded
music
and playing the films up until
midnight potentially one o'clock um
during the week would be an issue to the
residents of this apartment
um in in addition to noise from the
regulated entertainment noise from other
activities for example customers
restaurant type noises up until half
past 12 i've passed one in the morning
um from up to 20 to 50 people
could be you know problematical even if
the the live music recorded music
element was not there if you can imagine
a room
full of 20 to 50 people enjoying
themselves
not unreasonably really um on an evening
you know it's going to be inevitable um
so
having reviewed the the sort of locality
um
this particular licensed premises is at
a disadvantage because it's structurally
attached to this residential property
and with entertainment noise especially
when it's at lower frequencies
it can be readily transmitted through
the structure of a building
and be clearly audible
within habitable rooms of the dwellings
um
so in my opinion um
the proposal to extend the hours on on
the first
and second floor um is really something
that um
is going to have a negative impact on on
the residents um
the noise would be clearly audible
within the residential premises
um and when i've looked at the
application i'm also looking at the
provision the license the provision for
for the premises
to be fully utilized so um serious
nuisance impacts could arise um for
residents who
are relaxing in the evening and even
sleeping you know at night
up until half past 12 um past midnight
um in my opinion this would be
completely unacceptable to residents
who would be able to hear the noise um
and um
there's no sort of the events could be
unrestricted there's no
obviously with the covid situation um
there's a limit on numbers and so on but
the license would
allow for um this type of entertainment
activity to go on until the early hours
of the morning
um just i know we're not supposed to
talk about the planning
situation but um in the absence of a
planning control it's
important that um you know consideration
is given to the fact that
um normally what happens in in um
sort of altering them town center for
example we
meticulously review planning
applications and
to ensure that um the
residential stroke commercial uses are
in sync with each other so it over the
last few years altering them town center
has seen an increase in
a number of residential um applications
so
from the planning side of things we
would look at i i review applications to
make sure that there's
proper measures in place to ensure that
the residential premises are not
impacted by commercial
we'd even recommend refusal for certain
residential applications if they're next
to licensed premises
we recommend mitigation measures glazing
etc to protect the residents
um so it's it's really important for
um you know the residents of these
apartments um so there's a permission
for residents to be at these apartments
and they really need to be
protected from live music
recorded music entertainment noise
at the neighboring premises so my
recommendation really is that the
licensing committee refuses the
application
i just want to add about the town center
location
um i accept that people live in town
centres
knowing that they're going to be busier
than other areas but what i do not
accept is that they should
be exposed to entertainment noise on the
other side of a party wall
up until potentially half past 12 1
o'clock in the morning
um i think that's very important so my
opinion is that
the members committee members have a
duty to ensure that um
the noise sensitive residents are not
exploit exposed to
um public nuisance um
exposing residents to public nuisance
we've had a number of scenarios across
the borough where um similar situations
exist
um you've got sort of licensed premises
next to
um residential and various conditions
have been imposed um
to sort of mitigate the noise but um you
know
circumstances like this in my opinion
really
it's a case of um not allowing that use
to be there
in the first place because even
if you've got 10 15 people on the other
side of a party ball
um having a good time irrespective of
music live music recording music there
is the potential for
noise to have a negative impact um you
know
on on the residence um
um i also made mention to the fact that
um i've had
um email communications with the
owner of the um the residential
apartments next door who's
obviously concerned about the impact the
live
music regulated entertainment will have
on any potential tenants
tenants are transient in nature but
obviously as an
owner it's an important consideration
really
um to ensure that you know the the the
um the apartments um are
the occupants of the apartments are not
negatively um
affected um
that's basically it really that this is
not a number of residential
um licensed premises in the area and the
majority of them are on the ground floor
and they have relevant conditions
this is different to other licensed
premises in that um
you know they want to have activities on
the first and second floor adjacent to
sensitive premises so that's really the
key concern
i accept it's altering him town center
busy area etc
but it's also a residential area and
there is a history of complaints
um relating to other licensed premises
in the area
so you've got residents complaining
about noise from them so
it's really about striking striking that
balance more than anything else
okay thank you miss ali um can i just
ask you then
so despite the the recommendation of the
conditions that you've
made for your submission
uh what you're saying is quite clearly
that that still isn't enough
to join the second and third floor
in my opinion no and based upon
experience in the borough
we've had cases where for example if i
was looking at this from a planning
application perspective i would be
requiring
um you know detailed information i
probably would recommend an objection
for permission
um because it's you've got a residential
use
adjacent to a licensed premises and so
that would that would be my view it's
imp we have to
look at protection of residential
immunity from a planning side of things
and obviously from a licensing side of
things we're looking at some
the prevention of public nuisance so um
my personal opinion and based upon um
experience that myself and colleagues
have
had across the borough is that um
despite the imposition of
conditions um you know you have
you have um noise complaints relating to
um premises this is you've got two
bedrooms and
a living room on the other side of
a party wall um
and you're gonna have live music
regulated entertainment
music from up to 32 people sat down
having
you know have it having a nice time in
which they're
rightly you know doing so but um it is
going to have a negative impact and
a residence who lives in the area who
chooses to live in the area
has the choice to walk away um from
the noise or they're in control
basically whereas a resident who's
actually
sort of if living adjacent to this
property they're going to be negatively
affected by noise
entertainment noise taking place next
door up until
half past 12 1 o'clock in the morning um
like i said before amy lives a few doors
down but you could have a young
professional
couple living next door sort of working
all day
coming home maybe going to the bars and
so on coming home at 11
10 to go into retire for the day and
then next door you've got some
entertainment noise up until half past
12 1 o'clock in the morning
um which is it's not appropriate really
but i just clarifying if you know i mean
i was under the impression that all
these properties 22 to 26a is it
they're in the block next door is that
correct
they're in what sorry in the block next
door to the
premises the common ground premises or
or are they spread out i was understood
next door so basically
sorry to interrupt you so there's um
common ground which is number 20
and then you have number 22 which is um
tsugo
kitchen i think um then you've got
number 24 which is a barber's shop and
then on the other side of 24 is 26
which is a another sugo but that's like
a sugo
i think a takeaway type premises so
directly above
each of those three premises is a flat
and sorry they're all separate
properties they're not all just one
block of flats with
different numbers then but they're all
separate properties aren't they
yes so so the the shops on the ground
floor are separate and
the flats above again are 22 to 26
a they're owned by the same person and
my understanding is they're going to
they're basically split into three
separate flats
thank you miss ali and does any of the
other committee members have any
questions for for the environmental
health officer
yes can i can i come in on that yeah
chair yes answer the book yeah
in terms of uh residents residential
properties how many are they in that
particular square
surrounding the market
surrounding the market now i'm aware
that recently over the last few years
there's been quite a lot of sort of
change in the area
um so i'm definitely aware that the
from 22 to 26 there's three residential
apartments there um there's some on
greenwood street
there are some on um market
um markets where i think market street
um
just let me have a look at my records
because we've had some complaints from
residents that um
so yeah yeah so this this there are
there's sort of dotted around it
above various residential premises i
think as far as the
offices there's solicitors and people
like that along greenwood street
we're talking particularly around that
square area
right so you've got the premises the
residents above um
um next door basically so above sugo
the hairdressers and so you're only
talking about those three then
yes and i is there is somebody to the
rear as well felicity mentioned in her
comments that there's a
a resident who lives to the rear of the
site um
as well has there been any objection
from that no
no um councillor but if i may we um
damien has been speaking with him um
he's a gentleman called sam
um and he has no objections to the
application whatsoever
another point is uh uh why isn't the
the property owner the uh the shop owner
the objector not present of this meeting
my understanding is all representation
my understanding is that he wasn't aware
of the application so
um i've obviously when i've made
um looked into um this application as i
do with every other single application
i've reviewed the planning history and
licensing history etc
um and um basically it wouldn't be
the thing is if he's a businessman in
the area
and he owns properties there i'm sure
he's not you know he's familiar with
what
how applications are considered and done
and he would be he would be aware of
what's going on
yeah i mean i can't comment on that all
i can say is that um
for example if it was a planning
application nearest residents are
notified by the planning authority
of the application whereas with
licensing applications
it's a case of notices that the
application premises i think
and something in the local press so i'm
not sure
i can't comment on that right
in terms of those flats
you're saying that have they ever been
inhabited
what have they been you what's the
history behind them
um my understanding is this permission
for residential um was from
um commercial i think they might have
been offices in the past
uh but they have been um
these two the adjacent premises i i
don't think has been occupied
um but there are plans as i said earlier
yeah the thing is there were offices
before
yes right uh
would you not think that you know people
that were wanting to say like
you mentioned you know for example
couples that might be working late
would it make any sense for them to buy
a flat in the middle of a market area
which is essentially
uh developed for as a nighttime economy
you know all the all the businesses
around there are restaurants
bars uh and specifically in that
market areas which is quite enclosed is
what's created
altering them the way it is and it's
developed so it does not make any sense
to have residential property
in that particular focus area you know
if anybody wants to live there by all
means they can live there but as
i think you've mentioned about the
resident amy was saying that he doesn't
mind
and aware of the fact that people come
and i mean who would want to live
right in the heart of a market which is
effectively a nighttime economy
yeah i understand worried about noise
and
you know disturbance and things like
that can you explain that
yeah well this residential permission um
has existed i understand uh prior to
certain sort of activities you know so
for example
um i'm not sure how long
um other licensed premises have been
there but my understanding is that this
residential permission permission
has existed um for some time
for some time um i can't categorically
say
exactly when uh but it has been some
years definitely
2012
maybe i think i'd have to have a look i
can't i can't
comment on the date that the permission
was granted um
but would you not think that the
businesses that they're that at the
moment
existing businesses will probably have
some kind of say
in instead of something that's not even
potentially
ready or prepared in any way so for you
know to
be looking at some it's you know for
example somebody wants to go live next
to
door to an airport and then complain
about the noise yeah
yeah i understand that i mean i'm
looking at the application
i'm looking at a noise sensitive
receptor that's there
and the neighboring licensed premises
who want to expand onto the first and
second floor
um other premises licensed premises in
the area i've got a list in front of me
and they all have forms of regulated
entertainment on the ground floor so
you've got pi
um who's at number 18 sugo
at number 22 the seller um there's
numerous restaurants
up and down um greenwood streets there's
blanche flower there's the one that
felicity
recommended earlier um i'm not against
the
nighttime economy economy in altering
them i inquiry especially in this day
and age
with kovid and the way um things are
going really
um i'm not against that but it's my duty
to protect
the noise sensitive occupants of a
residential property that would be
impacted by
you know thorough you know noise it does
seem to be strange
just to finally i just say it does seem
a bit strange that you know if you were
sensitive to noise
the last thing you'd be wanting to do is
go and pitch yourself right in the
middle of a
nighttime economy uh an entertainment
venue effectively you know
very and it's a very enclosed pocket you
know that square
uh if you were on the high street that
would be different you know
yeah it's spread out or somewhere else
but you know
it the the that's a uniqueness of the
market area
uh is not reflected in other areas yeah
whether you may get residential people
point totally noticed but what i have to
point out is that
you've got numerous residents you've got
numerous entertainment venues
licensed premises that have conditions
um which control noise from those
license premises
with it so the noise is actually
contained within the premises
and also there's restrictions there's
conditions restricting
noise in the external areas up until i
think 2300
at the latest so there are controls
we've got a mixed area we've got to sort
of highlight that
we have a mixed area there's apartments
of
on um near to the town hall um
overlooking that area as well so we
don't have a strictly
um sort of commercial area it is a mixed
area
which which department are you talking
about overlooking the town hall um
there's some apartments market square or
market streets
overlooking the um to the
rear inside of the town hall we've had
some complaints from there
um but just going back to the point
again of
this this actual residence my issue is
about somebody who's living next door to
a
an entertainment venue and being
impacted by the noise
i know people choose to live in altering
them town center
and and they understand the noise and
the impacts and there
are controls on licensed premises but
here we've got
a residential premises which was there
you know is is permitted for
for a number of years um and the
neighboring licensed property wants to
have
um licensed activities up until at the
early hours of the morning
absolutely okay that's it have fun okay
sorry i'm just going to say that you
might not be aware that sugo
itself is licensed and the we're talking
about the flat above sugo sugo itself is
licensed
and i've employed the chef that used to
work there the head chef and
they play music when they're serving the
food and at the end of service
so i do understand your concerns
nurturing but regardless of whatever
happens with that the noise for that
flat above is not going to
you know it's going to get noise
directly above sugo which is a bustling
restaurant that's open
until 11 it's licensed i think until 11
o'clock and then plays music while they
clean down
so to think that there's going to be no
noise going through the ceiling and
affecting this flat regardless of what
happens with my application is
can i
just go back to your original question
chair just to get straight in my own
mind
is the only flat which has got a common
party role with
the applicant number 22 and number 24 26
and further down the street
is that correct yeah
yeah yeah and then is there another flat
at the back
of this premises that has a common party
world
one there's just the one flat that has
a common party ball that's what we're
twenty-two number twenty-two yes yeah
thanks uh somebody mentioned a bit of
flat being at the back
i couldn't visualize um council
brotherson it's overlooking there are
flats along greenwood street
yes there's back over the backyard of
common ground and
yeah but no common party wall just the
backyard
just going back to damien's point about
sugo i understand what he's saying about
zuko
sugo has a license uh but there's
controls on that license
and basically they're not allowed to um
be open beyond 11 p.m so at 11 p.m
um it's total silence at sugo
but what you're proposing is going to be
noisy up until potentially one o'clock
in the morning
or not one o'clock nazareth you know
well the premises will be open till 12
30 and so you've potentially got noise
on the premises
on the first floor up until 12 30 a.m
every day every night of the week and i
just ask you you refer to
other complaints obviously not relating
to this
premises what what do you mean by all
the complaints and what what what about
we've had complaints of um specifically
in relation to altering them so there's
other licensed premises in the area
one thing is very important to know is
altering him town center in
and this market area is not strictly
just licensed premises
it is a mixed area there are residential
premises in the area
and we have had complaints from
residents about
um adjacent um you know residential
premises noise from patrons outside
um noise from um doors and windows being
open noise from various sort of
entertainment activities
but it is fair to say that the licensing
conditions
relating to the majority of the licensed
premises in the area
are sufficient in sort of
dealing with the problem so if we do
receive complaints
um you know licensing or our team sort
of go out and speak to the licensee
just looking at one i've got here um in
relation to
a licensed premises complaint in 2017
2018 noise from um
sort of customers um outside and
music entertainment activities and so on
in the area
um okay
i just want to distinguish those
complaints as
specific against specific complaints
obviously
um counsellor brotherton or any of the
panel members do they have any other
questions
they have a question counselor sorry oh
joanne
yeah can i just ask natharien um the
application
um also includes uh the use of the
outside area to the rear of the property
yes would that have an impact on
residents um at the rear of the property
um if the application license you know
people were allowed to sit outside
um and drink until midnight well um i've
agreed with felicity a condition
which restricts the use of the external
area to the rail
until nine o'clock i think so after 9 pm
there should be nobody
in that external area so so that
protects
residents to the rear equally to the
front there is a
an external area and we've agreed both
agreed a condition
um restricting the use um until 11
o'clock i think nobody should
um so there are controls in place and
we're not personally not against
the premises or you know licensed
premises in the area but what is
important is
all of the majority i think 99 of the
licensed premises in
altringham town centre and in particular
in this area
are um located on the ground floor
um whereas this is on the first floor
and
from a planning point of view i received
numerous planning applications and
you meticulously going through planning
applications to ensure that
um you know occupants are not negatively
impacted by
noise from commercial uses so a few
weeks ago i dealt with an application
for
a an office next door to a um
residential property and you really have
to
sort of make sure there's appropriate
noise mitigation
and appropriate some glazing acoustic
ventilation etc
to protect the occupants and what we've
got here is a scenario where
um you've got entertainment activity
taking place
on the other side of the party wall of
you know noise sensitive premises
and the absence of any planning control
it makes it more
important for us to ensure that um you
know
the sort of public nuisance is is
prevented from this
activity and it's live music recorded
music
um you know playing the films i've had
complaints in altering them
of restaurants um where there's no um
there's just recorded background music
but the just the sheer number of um
sorts of customers and
when i say sheer number 20 30 customers
at one time
on the other side of the party wall it's
inevitable that there's going to be
noise
and disturbance um you know and add to
that
regulated entertainment um yeah
it's yeah sorry come on physical
felicity
sorry chair may i ask a couple of
questions off now
it's your turn now it's your turn to ask
some questions
thank you just just one or two um
obviously we're not talking about other
licensed premises in the area we're
talking about
the application for this one have you
had
any complaints relating to common ground
as it trades currently as its trades
my understanding is common ground have
had this license since about 2017
and there's been appropriate conditions
on the license
to contain noise only on the ground
floor because
on both sides you've got commercial
premises so on the right to common
ground you've got a commercial property
on to the left you have a commercial
property
and um you know there's been conditions
to
to contain the noise because the time
that the noise would be
particularly um disturbing to residents
or anybody would be sort of
later on in the evening um nazarene
sorry sorry so that's
so no is the answer no there'd be no
complaints in relation to
the way in which damian has been
operating thus far
no not on the ground floor now okay um
and i just wanted to ask you about
safeguards
because what i'm struggling to
understand is that you say that
some conditions are appropriate
and offer those safeguards so for
example
the condition relating to the use of the
space outside to the rear
prevents its use post 9 pm
and in addition to the front restricts
its use post 11 pm
those conditions seem to be satisfying
you in the you're confident that damien
will
adhere to those and if he does then then
noise
issues won't arise but i i don't know
why i'm struggling to understand why
you believe some conditions will um help
but then others don't you recommended a
condition
ppn 3 in your representation which we've
agreed
and if if that is adhered to
surely it must therefore follow that a
nuisance
will not be caused right so
i don't have any issues with damon
damien or his capability to control
noise from the premises um so
i i don't have an issue with that my
issue with
is with the actual facts of the
situation and the facts
are that you have a
a building basically you've got a party
wall and on the other side of the party
wall you have
um you know a noise sense you've got two
bedrooms
and you also have um a lounge
and noise from the entertainment
activities
is is going to um you know be audible
um it's going to be a problem too why
why will it the condition specifically
says that
any noise emanating from the premises
shall be
inaudible so it's not to cause a
nuisance so i don't
i'm struggling to understand why you
think that it's inevitable that an issue
will occur
if we've got a legally binding
requirement to make sure
that it doesn't yeah i can only speak
from
personal experience so we've i do not
you know experience dealing with other
premises in the area you've got here
um a licensed property that's
structurally attached to
a residential property entertainment
noise
especially at low frequencies it can
readily transmit through the structure
of a building
and be clearly audible with inhabitable
rooms of these dwellings
um so i
i don't think there may be a condition
there to protect that but
whether the structure of the building
allows damien to do that is another
issue
altogether if the imposition of that
condition on the license will make sure
that he has to do whatever it takes
to make it inaudible so what what
whatever it takes otherwise he'll be
guilty of a of a criminal offence
sorry i don't understand so you said
that the the
you fear that the structure of the
building
might give rise to a nuisance but
we have agreed a condition that you've
suggested
that means that damian will have he'll
have a legal requirement to do whatever
it takes
to make sure that that condition isn't
breached
so if there are i'm not saying that
there are but if there are structural
defects in that wall he'll have to
remedy them
i i'm looking at the application as it
is and i
there's nothing that you've put forward
to me to say that
um you know any measures are going to be
sort of acceptable to do that um
but we've agreed the condition that
you've requested um i think perhaps i'll
and i've i'm assessing the application
i'm assessing the application
and obviously damien is a is
is a licensee i'm looking at the
application premises and
the potential for impact to the
residential
properties and um i don't have
information
in front of me to say that the neighbors
are not going to be impacted negatively
and experience of dealing with other
premises in the area where
the license has been granted for
a licensed venue adjacent to residential
we're dealing with noise nuisance cases
um you know
there's clearly problems residents are
being infected affected by
um by the noise from the property
irrespective of
imposition of conditions because of the
structure of the building that's
something that's um
you know i can't control damien can't
control he can
put measures in place but um in my
opinion it's inevitable that noise is
going to be audible
in the neighboring residential property
i don't have any further questions but
obviously um we'll sum up in due course
thank you chair
okay i think actually unless there's any
questions for the environmental health
or any further questions i think we'll
move to the
uh summing up which uh um
nazarene is environmental health the
representative would you like to
start with something or something
yeah basically i mean just really
i appreciate them the position of the
applicant and it's important to
highlight that the area is a mixed area
it's not wholly
commercial with licensed premises there
are a number of
residential premises in the vicinity
this residential
property has been permitted um
to be there prior to
any application made by the applicants
and
you know it's important for the
occupants to be
um protected from um
any public nuisance that is likely to
arise as a result of
um you know entertainment noise up until
or 12 o'clock half past 12 every day of
the night
um and those residents don't have
control of
um walking away from okay they have a
choice to live in
in the town centre but they do not have
control of
being able to switch off entertainment
noise at
a certain time that's going to go on
until 12 12 30.
um so i just recommend that um the
counsellors take that into consideration
and it's also
important to know that other licensed
premises in the area are
really on the ground floor um as opposed
to
sort of second floors adjacent to
residential premises
thank you thank you nicely um
mr look do you want to uh sum up for the
afternoon
yes thank you chair um yeah i just want
to sort of bring it back
to the the facts of the application
and what we do know about it
there's been a lot of speculation about
what might happen in the future
but before you is an application for a
premises license
until midnight plus 30 minutes daily
on the ground first and second floors
with a set of conditions which we
formulated as part of an
operating schedule and which has been
further enhanced by the agreement to
additional conditions as proposed by
nazarene
it is a predominantly commercial area
there are some residents nearby
but the majority of the use in the area
is commercial
there has been one objection from
nazarene
nothing from the police nothing from the
licensing authority itself
nothing from any of the other
responsible authorities and no
objections from the resident
much concern is being given to um
the landlord of the adjacent flats
but he was perfectly able
to lodge an objection during the
consultation process
but didn't um
and we don't know if those
uh that flat that has the party war
will be developed we don't know if it is
when it will be we don't know who may or
may not choose to live there and it
would be a choice
and as councillor but identified earlier
that person would take that flat knowing
the area within which it was situated
we don't believe that noise nuisance
emanating from the premises is
inevitable
at all far from it damien is an
experienced licensee
you've heard that he has been running
his existing premises which benefits
from a license
without any issues whatsoever there's no
evidence to suggest that if he were
allowed to move into the upper floors
um that a nuisance would occur you've
heard that the
capacity um even postcovid
is not large uh particularly on the
second floor
um it may be chair that
um the use of the second floor in your
opinion that you are some questions
relating to it
uh might not be in your view suitable
for the playing of live and recorded
music up there
um but big due to its size um
but it's certainly demons uh wish to be
able to
provide it on the ground on the first
floor
um so we'd ask that the license is
granted in its amended form
um and that is with the reduced hours um
which was offered some time ago to
nazarene
together with the conditions which he's
asked that that be attached
to it um because there are other
safeguards in place
if and damien is absolutely confident it
will never arise
but if there should be an issue going
forward there are numerous
ways in which um he can be taken to task
or situations can be addressed and so
balance in my view needs to be struck
between allowing damien to develop his
business in what is a very challenging
time
against the needs of uh future residents
and i'm not saying for one second that
they mustn't be considered
but we need to uh strike a balance uh in
my view
and that balance i think is met with the
reduced hours
and the uh the imposition of the
conditions which we've
we've talked about so i'd ask you in the
strongest possible terms to to grant the
license
thank you thank you mr
and i just asked the legal officer to
summarize please for the uh committee
yeah i don't think i've got anything to
add at this stage other than what's
already been said but obviously i'll
retire with you all and if you have any
questions i can answer them then
right are we going to um notify all
parties in writing or
are we going to notify them yeah yeah
they needn't actually stay on the call
really then
that that's the matter for you i believe
you can come back into the meeting after
we've made a decision but they will
subsequently have a decision in writing
anyway
right okay well i'd prefer to do that i
mean it's up to them if they wish to
hang on we don't know
we don't know how long we're going to be
deliberating really it's quite
to go through to be honest um okay so
um i think we'll uh we'll ask our uh
our administrator to put us into the uh
into the closed session if